yes so my name is emilia dalliani i'm
italian i'm 26 years old
and i am now currently in brussels for
the blue book traineeship i am
actually delving into many different
things and aspects of my job during my
traineeship which is five months
i mainly
focused on together with my supervisor
on the
program of the eu careers student
ambassadors which are ambassadors
in different eu universities that
we organize events for and that are have
the task and the role of promoting
new careers in their universities i also
delved a bit into the world of social
media
for instance by writing a social media
report for the very first time which was
very exciting for me
and i
addressed some topics such as diversity
and inclusion
first highlight of my traineeship was
to get to know how the institutions work
from the inside and since epso is an
office that works with all institutions
we are having a good deal of experience
with
working with the council the commission
and and the other institutions in
brussels and luxembourg so this allows
you to have a first-hand experience of
what it means to
see the
processes from institution to
institution in the
in an office and all at the same time
the second would be
to
also get to know
eu official and staff
because i had to be in a team and i had
to integrate myself in the team that i
was working with
and this was also one of the highlights
because uh the colleagues indeed were
very uh in my unit were very welcoming
and very eager to involve me and all the
tasks that they were doing uh in these
five months
the other highlight i would say
is the possibility of networking not
only with fellow colleagues but also
with
other blue book trainees since there are
more than 900 blue book trainees for
each cohort then it is very easy to just
participate in social events or even
some conferences together and to get to
know people from all over the eu and
that are doing the same experience that
one easily well i actually
enjoy brussels a lot i think it is a
city that is on one hand very diverse
because a lot of
different people from different eu
countries and not only and beyond are
living in brussels
so it is not unusual to hear
and listen to many different languages
and when while one is in brussels and
languages being one thing that i really
like
then brussels is the ideal place to be
i also
didn't expect brussels to be very green
but it is
you have a lot of different parks and a
lot of different corners that it takes a
while but you will be able to
discover find out about and enjoy also
with the colleagues or the trainees that
you're gonna meet while in brussels uh
and definitely the fact of being very
close to the eu institutions allows you
to really be an experience uh the eu
bubble the euro bubble as they call it
to see really the council the parliament
the commission buildings and really
have the feeling of being part of the
european family and of the big machinery
which is the european institutions